JIM: (whistles) North!
-Yeah!
-HUDSON: Yeah!
-JIM: We're goin' in the canoe!
-TORI: Come on, in the boat,
please.
Good boy!
Okay, hon, ready?
JIM: We're heading back to camp
with the wood we foraged.
HUDSON: Yeah!
JIM (off screen):
All right, perfect!
We made it through
the first night no problem,
but now, we wanna make the site
a little more comfortable,
so we'll use the wood
to build some furniture,
so we can make it
as much like home
for the kids as we can.
We'll have to build
a lotta things like this
when we live off-grid,
so it'll be good
practice for all of us.
Look, honey, we're home!
TORI: This is so relaxing,
actually, eh?
-JIM: Oh, I love it.
-TORI: To have this all
-set up, and--
-JIM: I know.
TORI (off screen):
Look at Wes sitting up,
though, eh?
-Sitting all the way
up on his own.
-JIM (off screen): Wow!
-He's doin' so well.
-TORI: Not even leaning.
JIM: Good job, Wes!
TORI:
Yeah, we're talkin' about you!
JIM (off screen):
You're doin' so good!
Since Wesley has been
diagnosed with FOXG1 syndrome,
it's been reiterated
to us with pediatricians,
with other specialists,
that bringing Wesley
out into nature,
exposing him to some elements,
the better it will be
for his development.
Wesley's core muscles
have really strengthened up
a lot, eh, Tori?
-TORI (off screen):
Yeah, big time.
-JIM (off screen): Yeah, just
from him sittin'
in the canoe, I bet,
-and just havin'
to keep stable there.
-TORI: Look at him.
Yay!
JIM:
I'm gonna be makin' furniture.
Should I make
a table or chairs first?
-TORI: Definitely a chair.
-JIM: Chair?
But what are you gonna sit on?
Just kidding.
Right now,
I am building a couple chairs.
I'm just taking
four pieces of wood
and making two triangles.
One of these triangles
is gonna be a seat,
and the other triangle
is gonna be a backrest.
I've always thought
it was interesting
to try to make
stuff for yourself,
ever since I was a little kid.
It's always fun
to see what you can
kinda make with your hands
with the materials around you,
as opposed to always relying
on store-bought items.
TORI: Before we left home,
Jim and I made a high-calorie
trail food called pemmican.
It's made
from dehydrated berries,
bison meat,
and rendered animal fat.
I'm adding it to a stew
with some veggies.
It's the perfect
high-nutrition meal
after a long day
of hiking and foraging.
JIM:
This is all just kind of
practice, if you will, for, um,
when we are gonna spend much
more time at an off-grid cabin
that hopefully we can build,
maybe in the near future.
Yeah, like that.
Like that.
Tori... Ready for a chair?
But crafted by the hand
of the Man of the Wilder,
-Jim Baird himself.
-TORI: Whoa!
-JIM:
That's nice enough for that...
-TORI: Plop it right there.
JIM:
...champion booty
of yours or what?
Huh?
TORI: Should I test it out?
-JIM: Yeah, there you go.
-TORI: I'm scared.
-JIM: No, it's good!
-TORI: Oh!
JIM:
Yeah, it's, kind of,
a lean-backy feel.
-TORI: Oh, I--
-JIM: Do you like it?
TORI: Yeah, I like this.
JIM: Look at mine, hon, huh?
-TORI: Look at you.
-JIM: Right?
(groans)
Oh, this one is great, too.
That is comfy. Look at that.
-That's chill.
Good job, honey.
-TORI: Good job!
-JIM: Good day.
-TORI: Crushed it.